[Music]
in our previous video we discussed the
two laws of reflection today we will do
one cool experiment that you can do at
your home to verify the laws cover a
table with a white sheet of paper take a
comb and cover all its openings except
the middle one you can use black paper
to cover them place the comb
perpendicular to the white sheet of
paper as shown now light up a torch
throw its light through the opening of
the comb from one side adjust the torch
in such a way that you should be able to
see the light on the white sheet of
paper next we place the plain surface of
the mirror in the path of this light
what did you see did the light get
reflected
yes you can clearly see the reflection
of light on the sheet of paper represent
this light with the incident ray and
reflected ray drawn on this white sheet
of paper like this also draw a normal to
the mirror surface
remember normal is a perpendicular line
drawn at the point of incidence what are
these two angles called this angle is
called angle of incidence and
represented by eye while this angle is
called angle of reflection represented
by our measure these two angles with the
help of a protractor the measure of the
two angles will almost be the same they
are approximately equal this is the
first law of reflection so with this
experiment you can verify this law well
if you're still not convinced you can
take further readings by changing the
direction of the incident light change
this angle of incidence by moving the
combs slightly make sure that the point
of incidence is the same in both cases
that is this point here is same as it
was previously but notice that this time
the angle of incidence is greater than
the previous one so by the first law of
reflection of light the angle of
reflection should also be greater and
that is the case indeed
both the angles and again you will find
that they are approximately equal take
two more readings to complete this table
do you notice anything strange here the
first law tells us that angle of
incidence is equal to angle of
reflection and not approximately equal
why am I using the word approximately
well there are chances of errors that
may come about during measurements of
things we can refer to them as human
errors it also depends on narrowness of
the light beam narrower this beam more
accurate will be the results and this is
the reason why we are passing a light
through the small opening of the comb
only a narrow beam of light from the
torch passes through the small slit this
minimizes the error in the measurement
also one more thing that we need to keep
in mind is that the beam of light is
different from the ray of light for
example in this experiment the light you
see is a beam of light a ray of light is
simply an idealization of a beam we can
see a beam but we cannot see a ray of
light however at this stage we can think
of ray of light as a narrow beam of
light and we will call this narrow beam
a ray of light
[Music]